of all congrats on the series having a
second season
thank you i have a bunch of questions
about that but everyone i talked to
uh during the pandemic gets the first
two questions
uh the first one being uh what tv series
do you want a guest star on
oh man that's a good freaking question
what tv show do i what like one that's
currently on right now
we also do we also accept answers like
older shows
but it's probably better if you mention
the newer ones that way if they ever
watch this interview they'll know
exactly
they'll know that i'm like so down you
know i love doing voiceover
cameos i love because the thing is like
not a lot of people
know that you're there like you know
that it's you and
the only way to take it out is like
they'll look you up and so like you said
like bojack horseman or something like
that
that'd be awesome that'd be really cool
uh what movie or movies do you think
you've seen the most
um i can definitely answer this one with
confidence
i've watched the star wars series
like all of them back to back
a disgusting amount of times i like just
just a revolting like i'd never be able
to get
a date if i told anybody how many times
i've watched star wars
and it's definitely the most the most
one is return to the jedi for sure
god now when you say you've seen the
star wars movies do you mean all nine do
you mean
solo rogue one oh i mean oh yeah
so like all nine like i go on little
missions of my own it's like so i'll
i'll do
the chronological order marathon
i'll do the order of release marathon
i'll uh
i'll do just the originals in a day i'll
just the prequels in a day i'll do just
sequels in a day i'll do something like
that uh sometimes i'll just randomize it
sure do you collect any star wars things
not much i the thing is like i
would like to but i'm not an organized
person and so any stuff that i'd collect
would just
end up just filling my room which is
already a
black hole full of everything that i've
ever collected in my life
you might not know this about me i am a
pretty big star wars fan
just throwing that out there um saying
that uh i'm sorry to say i hate
episode nine uh i hate episode nine yeah
i really i really hate it
and i'm just curious what you think
about it because i think it destroys the
original
trilogy by bringing back the emperor i
go back and forth when it comes to the
sequel trilogy a lot
i'm pretty set in my ways with the with
the prequels
like the way i look at the prequels is
like
you love the prequels because you love
star wars
like you know when you have like like a
crappy sibling
like you know when you're like fighting
with your sibling and you're like i love
you
because you're my sibling but
you're an answer you know what i mean
like this is like you you kind of accept
it because you need to because it's star
wars and then the sequels
the sequels what i think i like about
them and appreciate about them
is that they especially in i think this
is more applies to episode
eight is uh they
they weren't afraid to break formula to
to break expectations even though
there was some fan backlash i prefer
eight to nine for sure
there is no comparison eight is a work
of genius compared to nine
wow i think the thing about i think with
seven and nine
all seven was to me was a reboot of a
new
100 like hope the most part it was great
to see the original characters
and this is nothing to do with the
filmmaking this has nothing to do with
the performances because those are the
the
saving graces of the movies to me i
think it's a visually as
they're all stunning movies i think the
performances are incredible
on on all fronts by everybody in the
cast for sure
it's just like so i was like okay so
where they got whence is going to
differentiate itself a little bit when
getting into
into the seventh movie and that's why i
think uh
i i like last jedi the most out of the
uh out of the sequel trilogy and i know
that's fans don't agree with that
i like it specifically because it felt
like they weren't making it specifically
to make a fan
a fan made star wars movie dude i could
first of all you're 100 right second of
all
right you're 100 right ryan johnson
it has its faults for sure listen i i
just realized i only have so much time
with you so i have to get all star wars
but believe me when i say i i we could
talk a lot more about star wars and
i'd like to but believe me i i could
this could be an hour-long conversation
but
it reflected too we could do it um
the next time the next time we talk
it'll be more star wars
a long one next time we talk i'd love to
get in detail for sure
so jumping into why i actually get to
talk to you so why
is it that people love prank shows
um i think i don't even i think why i
like prank shows
is uh what i would do when i was younger
because i
i didn't really get into him too much uh
but i watched punk a couple times and
the reason i always like watching punk
is because i would always like to just
think
about like what if what if i got to be
on one
so that was basically my mentality going
into watching any of those
and so i guess that might have been a
big motivation as to why
i decided to go along with the project
for sure
one of the things that when i'm when i'm
watching the episodes
i i wonder how many times did you get to
a point where you're like really
freaking out or
nervous that someone could fly off the
handle and do something bad
uh every single prank at every single
moment that we've ever done
that's a constant fear
that's a constant anxiety and this isn't
just for me this is my first
time ever experimenting with a project
it's even remotely similar to anything
like this
but most of the people on our set have
done many frank shows
have done some of the biggest prank
shows are our main writer
and producer kevin he uh
he created scare tactics he worked on
scare tactics for
quite some time i believe he worked i
don't know if he worked on punks but he
did famous and he'd done a lot of
hidden camera shows he's done a lot of
hidden camera reality non-scripted shows
and so he's a veteran and every single
prank
he comes in shaking shaking
i'm like how you feeling he's like oh
man i should have went to the bathroom
before this
we always say things we're always like
oh we should have gone to the bathroom
before we started this because they take
hours and it's
just nothing but nerves constantly but
the thing is is that then you get to the
reveal
and then once those usual those usually
go smoothly
the relief is so worth
the hours of borderline crapping your
pants
it's it is it's worth it and that's kind
of like it's funny like going into it in
a day
i'm like sometimes i'm even like i'm not
for it today i don't want to do this
today
it's stressful and then throughout the
whole prank i'm like
come on and then then the reveal happens
and then it's like
okay i remember why we do this i
remember why i enjoy coming to work and
doing this because it is quite fun
what do you think is the craziest things
that the writers have come up with
and have have they has there been
anything thus far that has been like
thought about and it hasn't been able to
be pulled off yet
just because it's too complex yeah uh
for sure
they uh they attempted for season two we
never got around to it we hope that if
there's gonna be a three
that we could attempt something like
this uh
where we prank three people at one time
two is already ambitious but like we
were hoping we we had some ideas about
perhaps like a big season two finale of
where we're going to prank three marks
instead of instead of just two
and we never got around to it and i
think that mainly was because
of our covet protocols because we had
the film during the pandemic
and filming a non-scripted with people
coming from their everyday lives
during the pandemic is quite the
challenge
yeah i actually don't know how now that
i'm thinking about that and like how do
you
how do you get them because they're
obviously coming in knowing that they
have like a day of work
yeah they're coming in for like uh so
basically our casting i don't really
this isn't really something that i'm
super super familiar with about the like
in-depth mechanics but i know the gist
of it is
our casting goes and
to a bunch of people who are looking on
like online sites
for like temp work dog walking uh
working with exterminator babysitting
all stuff like that
and we put our applications into it and
people can go
and sign up and they're like uh
temp work for paying this much and it's
it's a pretty
for for for a day's work it
isn't shabby what we put on the website
uh and so a lot of people
end up clicking on and then we go from
there and they evaluate and talk to them
about like in person about uh
them personally and what this does is it
gives us an idea and they ask pretty
specific questions
which to them seem random but to us are
very important into knowing how they're
going to react to the situation like
this
and that we have um a lot of times we'll
have people who
uh understand mental health and
and and how people are going to react to
certain stressful situations because we
are aware that we're putting people into
a situation
that will turn stressful and so the last
thing we want to do
is to put anybody who will be severely
uncomfortable and
just not okay with the situation like
that that's the worst fear that we have
because all this is is we're just trying
to have some fun and we want to make
sure that when all is said and done
that they had a good time too that's
what we don't want to make fun of
anybody we actually want to make sure
that
what they do shows that they are good
leaders
and that they can take control of a
stressful situation
and help help those around them and
that's the goal of getting two people
who don't know what's going on
and having them uh deal with a situation
in which our actors are told to be as
incompetent as possible
if that's what our actions main goal is
to do sure if you
sorry to me to interrupt but no if
someone hasn't seen an episode yet of
season one or season two after it
premieres
what's the episode you want them to
start with what's the episode i want
them to start with
wow that's a good one i would actually
say
don't start with episode one of season
one because
that's one of the
i guess i don't want to say hokey no i
do want to say hokie for sure
um like i think that's the one where
like the teddy bears come to life
and stuff like that so i'd say start a
little bit smaller i think one of the
best ones i'd say
is uh uh camp scarecrow
okay that's the one where uh um
quote unquote the scarecrows uh now
maybe come to life either that
or it is also debated that uh the old
groundskeeper
has kind of lost his marbles and is now
going on a bit of a rampage
take revenge on the camp and the reason
i say to start with that one is because
it kind of diff it kind of pulls back
from the supernatural
elements of it all because a lot of them
deal with things like ghosts one of them
in our second season is uh people
working in a haunted house
and one of the cool things we do with
that is
one of our marks is working with what
they believe to be
is a temp security company and they're
going to be there
literally just watching monitors in the
house to make sure the moving is going
swimmingly
and we we have little edits that we are
able to put into the security cams
that show are some actors walking
downstairs but like you can see through
their bodies
and the other actors they are completely
unaware of the situation going
and like and it's pretty stuff like that
it's pretty cool but this one
became scarecrow isn't as supernatural
and so it's more of like
this is crazy and it shows you the
stakes and it shows you the mechanics of
what the franchise is going to look like
without it going to any territories
where people could look at it and say
come on that's not real
which is com which is a completely
understandable
reaction to have when looking at a show
like this it's if i would ever watch
this
from an outsider's perspective i
probably would just
be like yeah right but
that's kind of my mission with these is
for people to be like just give it a
shot
and uh of course take it with a grain of
salt but it is quite some fun
uh i know that you can sing and i'm just
curious i try
well listen i i know you can my question
is do people refuse to do karaoke with
you because you're a ringer
[Music]
no one ever refuses to do karaoke with
me i'm usually one i i won't
hesitate to get up on that mic myself
usually people have a lot of fun doing
karaoke with me
especially when whenever i'm singing
with people like in a fun setting i
uh i'm usually not too focused on my
technique in that moment
so i understand you you're there to i
get it you're there to have fun
i'm fine obviously before i uh uh
let you go uh of course as a huge fan of
stranger things i want to ask you
um you know about uh the series and one
of the things that i think
is going to be great about the upcoming
series is that uh
sean and the duffers have said that all
the scripts were done
um in advance you know they had more
time to work on the scripts
so i'm just curious before to talk about
well a did they give you all the scripts
in advance or were they were they
giving it out piecemeal and what was
your reaction to them and did you feel
like the writing this season is
really good that's an incredible
question because
the first couple seasons is know that a
goal would the goal was
never to film before this before the
show was finished being written
that was never a goal that's just how it
ended up happening in the first three
seasons is we we have a certain number
of episodes written around five or six
out of eight or nine is usually what
we'll start filming with once those are
written
and the goal is that they'll they'll
direct
and write at home they'll be home and
that's when they'll that's when they'll
write
on the side and just they'll manage
their workload that way and how it's
always worked out is
is we're about like we're on episode
four or five and we
haven't seen episode six and seven yet
and we have no idea what's gonna happen
and they haven't even written all of it
yet and so the pressure is usually on
and when that happens
usually there's like a two to three week
hiatus where we'll go home
and take a break and during that two to
three weeks matt and ross are home
and they are right
like non-stop panic writing like
i didn't write my essay and
english class starts in five minutes
typewriting and
that's never ideal but honestly for some
reason that spur of the moment
uh we gotta get this done it seems
to me like that's where a lot of their
best work comes in
and i don't know if it's the pressure i
don't know if it's
them being up all night all caffeinated
and they just have like
really crazy frazzled brains that can
write really weirdly
i know a lot of comedic writers who will
stay up
into all hours of the night like playing
video games and drinking red bulls
so they can get to that kind of
delirious tired state
and then be better at like just coming
up with random stuff off the top of
their heads because they're a little bit
more delirious
i don't know if that assists them or not
but this year because of
coven there's no excuse for them not to
have the series written completely
when we went in uh for our first table
read which was
february of 2020 so last year we
expected to go right into filming and it
was gonna be the same situation
they were gonna start with episodes all
the way up from one through five and
we'll probably do the same hiatus
but kobet hit and we only had like six
episodes and so they're like we might as
well finish
where are you in the filming process are
you guys because of covid
are you rapping in like june have you
like where what's going on
there's very few dates that are reliable
it really is more of like a
guesstimation on
when we're going to be filming next uh
when we're going to be wrapping up when
release is going to be
all that jazz because we still don't
know what a day-to-day if we're going to
be filming next week
yeah i should be filming like next month
for like
a big chunk a bigger chunk than i've had
in a bit but
even though it's coming up in about two
weeks from now i still don't know an
exact date
so because of that there's really no way
to figure out when we're going to be
rapping
i think that they've been able to relish
in their directing in their day to day
there's nothing else distracting them
other than what we're going to do
today while we're directing and i asked
them i'm like do you guys sleep at night
they're like literally
we dream about directing the show we go
to sleep
and we have dreams that we just are
directing the show it takes up their
entire minds
when they're making this and so i think
now that the i think it's a good thing
because they now they
can take their focus on off of what the
show is going to be about
and now that they know it they can focus
on how they're going to deliver
and i think it jokes